sur ce plateau khattar abou diab
politologue spécialiste du moyen-orient
bonjour merci d'être avec nous réaction
du premier ministre de l'autorité
palestinienne
il a dit que cet accord je cite c'est
pour éviter la destitution à trump a
évité la prison un netanyahu se dit du
siècle comme le présente le président
américain est ce que c'est vraiment une
diversion politique comme le prétend le
premier ministre de l'autorité
palestinienne
en effet ces deals des siècles cet
accord dix siècles ou plutôt ses plans
proposés par israéliens et américains
ensemble par rapport aux palestiniens
c'est vrai et les en gestation depuis
trois ans depuis l'élection de monsieur
trempe
mais ce qui est vrai aussi qu'il est
proposé en pleine année électorale
américain
presque un mois avant de les troisièmes
élections israéliennes au cours des
derniers mois et pour cela personne ne
sera qu'un plus c'est demander
légitimement si cet accord n'est pas lié
aux nécessités aux contraintes
électorale soit des messieurs tram peut
soit démissionner tailleur par des
nécessités électorales alors que les
palestiniens eux menacent de
se retirer en des accords d'oslo si vous
mettre leur menace à exécution qu'est-ce
qu'il faut après ce qu'il faut
s'attendre
derrière vous savez les palestiniens
sont dans une passe très embarrassante
très difficile très critique
l'accord d'oslo est pratiquement tombées
depuis l'assassinât de rabin et depuis
le division interpalestinienne et avec
aussi l'ambiguïté dans cet accord doit
maintenant c'est abbas le président de
l'autorité palestienne parlé hier de la
fin de la fonction de l'autorité
palestinienne c'est ça c'est le propre
je pense qu'il va attendre les élections
israéliennes avant de prendre des
décisions définitives concernant la
rupture définitive avec les autorités
israéliennes a vu un sur les premières
images
la bande de gaza commence déjà à se
manifester à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre prochainement certaines
personnes ont dit que cet accord de paix
pouvait mettre de l'huile sur le feu ce
qu'il faut s'attendre à une nouvelle
intifada à gaza en manifestent à
ramallah ou dans la en cisjordanie il y
à des manifestations dont beaucoup de
compétitionner à l'étranger et dans
d'autres pays il y a toujours des
réactions les les problèmes pour les
palestiniens c'est le problème de
l'unité palestinienne
est-ce que cet accord pousse les fatah
et le hamas le des principales
organisations à unifier les efforts
c'est un test pour eux un test pour le
mouvement de libération nationale
palestinien s'il est capable de défier
ses efforts car l'ia et rap ont profité
tellement de cette division
ils ont joué sur les cordes de cette
division pour est allé bien la loi on a
vu des réactions de la communauté
internationale
paris de son côté insistent sur une
solution à deux états en conformité avec
le droit international est ce que ça
veut dire que la france un signe qu
israël ne respecte pas le droit
international
je pense qu'elles les européens les
russes les chinois et les autres
elle répète les mêmes choses c'est à
dire l'attachement à sa solution de deux
états et au respect du droit
international les américains avec trump
applique les faits accomplis sur le
terrain c'est un pro israélien présenté
par les américains c'est la réalité
mais c'est vrai que peut-être aux yeux
des américains
c'est le seul moyen de sortir de
l'impasse car les israéliens n'ont
jamais accepté l'idée de frontière
limiter cette fois apparemment ils
acceptent l'idée de frontière limité
c'est vrai c'est aligné contre les paris
c'est un complot c'est vrai qu'il est
favorable aux israéliens car il
interprète un rapport de force très
défavorable aux palestiniens pour
revenir sur ma tension sur paris qui a
commenté cela t'est ce qui veut dire
paris là dessus si je parie dit que je
serais pas
c'est pour paris et toute l'union
européenne ont été invités à cette
cérémonie
ils ont refusé d'aller donc il n'y a pas
une caution européenne pour ses plans
par de la cause européenne coûte de la
caution russe puisqu'on sait que
benyamin nétanyahou après ouais si on
cherche la couronne britannique
les britanniques vont partir d'enquêtés
l'europe dans des jours donc on cherche
accent britannique
hier les selles des gens étrangers des
cités par 36 t ball johnson et on
cherche surtout la coopération russe
aujourd'hui les vice ministre russe des
affaires étrangères
ce clip de run allemand messer bogdanov
l'a dit clairement c'est un c c'était
une proposition parmi d'autres et c'est
aux parties concernées décidé donc je
pense le russe ne disent pas un lot
catégorique à cette à cette proposition
à ses plans mais le russe nenê cherche
pas aussi être un rouage de ces
processus dernière question qatar abou
diab donald trump avait dit avant même
de dévoiler son plan de paix
il avait dit avant-hier que son plan a
une chance d'aboutir
et dans le même temps après que ce plan
a été dévoilé le chef de la diplomatie
de la jordanie je cite a dit que
l'annexion de la vallée du jourdain
mettra fin aux choses de paix alors du
coup cette question est ce qu'il ya une
chance de paix ou est-ce qu'il ya plus
de chances de paix écoutez une solution
de la paix mis à part comme je dis il ya
celui ci une tentative d'une solution
imposée
c'est vrai les réactions arabes il ya
des réactions arabes depuis la partition
de la palestine en 1947 jusqu'à
maintenant il y avait des guerres des
tentatives il y avait des surenchères
iranienne très haute mais rien n'est
fait les palestiniens sont les perdants
maintenant tout dépend s'il ya un
interlocuteur palestinien
pour le moment les plus gros problèmes
pour les américains et les israéliens
il n'y a pas d'interlocuteurs
palestiniens les palestiniens dans leur
écrasante majorité un énorme de baisse
mais mahmoud abbas estime que c'est pas
faisable c'est pas une proposition ce
que c'est un diktat et c'est ça les
fonds de problème c'est vodafone merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur ce plateau d'ayrté france
khattar abou diab je rappelle que vous
êtes politologue spécialiste du
moyen-orient'